Hello everybody!
We're finally here.
Oh my goodness.
We're finally at the finale of Doom 64 finally.
Hi Minto!
Hello!
hour stream no it can't be five hours because i have another
stream in two hours and obviously didn't you see the title
the title is how to beat doom 64 final boss tutorial
so i've been stuck on her for a month i got you i got you i
have the cheese Fresh cheese.
Actually, it's not fresh.
It's been, it's been marinating for, for years.
That's the good stuff.
The smelly bits.
Ah, that's the cheese.
That's the cheese.
Spoiled cheese, no!
Spoiled cheese just becomes blue cheese.
There's no such thing as spoiled cheese.
Do I understand the stream title correctly?
It's the final boss tutorial on how to beat Maid Vint
Phantom.
What?
I'm not the final boss.
My Goshijin-sama or Joe-sama would be the final boss.
I'm just a maid.
Stop it.
Show us the weird speedrun strats on this boss.
I got you.
I think.
I like my cheese like I like my Oshi.
Aged to perfection with great patience.
Yeah, you'll need patience.
Here.
I think.
Have patience with me.
You know?
Also, what do you mean?
What do you mean, aged?
I haven't aged a day since I died, so...
I haven't aged literally a day since I died.
A ghost don't age?
That doesn't matter what age you die at.
I...
I'm forever 19.
Good luck with the final boss.
Could I get a happy birthday from the silly goose maid,
please?
Austin, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Austin.
to a you happy birthday yeah after three weeks of my surgery
pain being gone it has returned in full force oh no Brandon
I'm so sorry well hopefully all the pain that I caused to
these demons will get your mind off of the pain that you
have right now I'm sorry if you never age does that mean
you're never wash what that's not the same thing what are
you talking about oh my goodness uh which one am i on i
think this one i think wait hmm i think i think i think this
one Second and the last one is the one before you died.
Oh, okay.
Minto, are you going to try and go to Aqua Final Main Live?
I saw they announced that today, right?
They may not be.
It's disbanding, but I felt a huge pit in my stomach seeing
the announcement.
Yeah.
It depends on when it is, right?
Depends on when it is.
Starting...
September I'm going to try and not travel so much so but I
mean if it's for something like that I'm kind of hoping that
maybe it will overlap with like another trip that I'm doing
we'll see PK Peter welcome to membership thank you yeah
though it's so sad I didn't get to you know I was actually
in japan during muse's final live um uh i was there but i
didn't have i never got i didn't get tickets but i actually
had to go to the tokyo dome area um to register some
paperwork and so but it was on this the day of the final
live that i went and so i saw like all the crowds around
Tokyo Dome and I was just like That should have been me So I
didn't I didn't get to see the show But I was there I was
there Just not there Because I got that I forgot to tell you
yesterday it was Ace Combat 29th anniversary 29th
anniversary Happy birthday Ace Combat 29 Oh my gosh That's
crazy The FOMO.
I know.
I had first-hand FOMO.
I was like, I was there.
I was watching everybody.
You know, I was going to say having fun, but they were
probably all sad.
So maybe not so much fun, but, you know, they were all there
existing.
Thank you for being you.
What did I do?
Oh my gosh, I just dropped my pillow.
I have my, I got my Ayami pillow in the other day.
If you went to the cafe that she had in Akihavara, the Ayami
Sensei cafe, she was selling it.
And you had to order it.
So it finally came.
And, and, oh my gosh.
I was looking at Ayami Sensei's fan box this morning.
And if you're subscribed to Ayami's fan box, you might have
seen something.
spoilers because it is kind of it is it is a paywall so i
saw did you see she tweeted it
i wasn't really on twitter much today because i have been
cleaning she did tweet it a little but there's something
else in there but you're all i'll retweet it i'll retweet it
there's something else in there mm-hmm there's something
else in there that is kind of funny but um if if you know if
you can't afford it that's totally fine too but it's kind of
funny a bonus yeah quite quite something a little silly
which I think is so funny especially i can't say much
because you know it's not my right to say but it does
involve me a yummy salesperson i just love a yummy okay guys
east time level 28 i'm going to try to cheese i'm going to
try the cheese and cheese i shall Do we believe?
Do we believe?
It's my birthday today.
I would really hate if you sang Happy Birthday.
It would be the absolute worst.
Just absolutely terrible.
Would it be even worse if I called you Woo-Me and not Wo-Me?
Happy Birthday to you.
Happy Birthday Dear Holy...
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, man.
Happy birthday to you.
It's time!
Come out.
Ah!
Yeah!
She na, she na, she na!
Everybody die, everybody die.
Everybody die!
Everybody!
All of them!
Oh shoot!
Okay, time to leave.
Time to leave.
Oh gosh!
Ah!
Hey!
Chill out!
Chill.
I'm doing the strats.
Oh my god We're strafing, we're strafing, we're strafing
That was me We're strafing, we're strafing, we're strafing
We're strafing, we're strafing, we're strafing, we're
strafing, we're strafing, we're strafing, we're strafing,
we're strafing, we're strafing, we're strafing, we're
strafing, we're strafing, we're
strafing, we're strafing, we're strafing, we're strafing,
we're strafing, we're strafing, we're killing, we're killing
We're killing them, guys!
I think we're doing okay, maybe.
We're strapping.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, oh, shoot.
Oh, shoot, oh, shoot, oh, shoot, oh, shoot.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, there's another spider.
Where did you come from?
shoot oh shoot oh shoot let's go back to oh my gosh let's
go back to rockets real quick oh my god this guy this big
guy got him uh where's okay hold on oh there's another big
guy okay and we can blow up this guy okay so far so good
sorry I can't really reach out Okay, I just have to be in
position once I...
Once I take him out.
Wait, who's still here?
Oh.
Okay, okay, okay.
Ah!
Okay, all right, all right, all right.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh shoot!
Oh no no no no!
This is the strut!
Yes!
I did it!
Just keep going!
This is the strut!
Yeah!
I did it!
I figured it out!
I got it!
It's not gonna kill him, it's not gonna kill him, but then
we switch here.
Yeah!
Whoa!
I
told you it's the strat!
I told you it's the strat!
tutorial.
I told you!
I told you how!
Five minutes, easy, baby.
I told you.
Five minutes.
Finally, the mother of all demons is dead.
The blood pours from your eyes.
as you stand in defiance as the only marine to endure the
slaughter you decide to remain in hell and ensure no demon
ever rises again the end thanks
to the stream i guess what now oh i don't know what now
thank you for the akasuba i didn't get to read it though
jino-chan thank you for the zombie man oh my gosh we get the
whole cast yay zombie man
short stream thanks everyone i didn't think i would be able
to pull it off for the first try though oh oh i shot him
Gun guy!
You want to watch me take him out?
Yeah!
Imp!
Oh no, he's trying to...
I'm gonna take him out!
We're gonna see his little butthole!
Butthole!
Oh god!
Nightmare Imp!
Ooh, I'm gonna take him out.
First try, first try.
Butthole!
Demon!
Um, call him what he's called.
That is a pinky.
Pinkie!
Pro tip, to defeat the mother of demons, shoot at her until
she dies.
Like a fine-aged Parmesan.
I can't believe!
Oh, Spectre!
Lost!
Oh, get out of here.
Coco Demon!
That was awesome, Strat, but are you enough of a gamer to go
for the true ending?
I want- wait, what's the true ending?
Did I miss the tutorial?
It's the fastest stream ever.
How'd I?
First shot.
First try, baby.
Baron of hell!
The loading screen took longer than the gameplay.
That's not true.
Arachnotron!
I like these guys a lot.
Pain elemental.
Kill this guy.
Guys, that guy sucks.
Stupid meatball.
Man kill bars.
The way they die is so nasty.
The cyber demon.
Whoa!
Me!
Hold on.
Ow!
It's me!
Well, guys, I do have another stream today.
That one will be longer.
I don't know what to do.
I'm...
Wait, how do I get out of this?
It's the same thing again.
Wait, hold on.
I'm not a shotgun guy.
Hold on, I'm not a shotgun guy.
Karaoke?
Okay.
We could do karaoke.
What do I do?
How do I leave?
Main menu?
This re-release has a few new bonus levels that serve as a
precursor to Doom 2016 if you want a few more levels to
play.
How do I get to those?
I thought Mint was stuck in the game.
Quitsh, do I just leave?
Oh, password.
Quit the main menu for now?
Pro gamer Minto, looking forward to Doom 3 when you feel up
to it.
Thanks!
I go to options, right, for the passwords?
Yeah.
What's under more?
Oh, nope.
Under password.
It's six maps, if I remember correctly.
Oh, new game?
I have to do new game?
Oh, the lost levels.
Okay, since I did say I will do karaoke, I'll do...
Maybe...
What, there's six of them?
Maybe I won't do all of them?
But, uh...
You cheesed so fast that you beat the boss before I got a
yummy spin box.
Good job, boss.
Share some of that cheese to us.
We're hungry.
Hmm.
Karaoke while playing the last levels.
Let's just do... I did bring it on before, right?
So, we'll just do the same.
Oh no, I don't have anything.
Uh...
I have nothing and nowhere to go.
Wow, thank you for the Hakka so far!
Karaoke sounds great, I love the idea of someone turning in
for a final boss tutorial and hearing giddy giddy eye.
Hey, hey, die, die!
Die, die.
Die, die, die now.
Yeah, we'll do karaoke.
Oh, my goodness.
Woo!
Hey!
Chill out!
Let's grab that.
I just opened something.
Gitty, gitty eye.
Eek and I borderline.
I miss having the better shotgun.
Oh!
I heard someone else.
I think I heard him.
And him.
Grab everything?
Where?
Oh, that guy.
Gitty, giddy eye.
Eek and knife.
For the...
Hello?
Oh!
Hey.
Borderline!
Well, it is, I mean, seriously, it was like a tutorial for
real.
I think people could actually watch my stream and be like,
so that's how you beat it.
So funny.
How that...
Aim, don't go.
So funny how that just kind of turned out like that.
But I only know because I watched a guy do it.
Wait, can I open this?
No.
I watched this some guy and he was like really good.
Oh, I hear someone going.
Where do I go?
Sorry if I'm like zooming through here.
Maybe I go through here.
Oh!
I don't want to go here yet.
I don't think.
Trim and re-upload the stream.
For real!
Oh!
Secret!
Is this level zero?
To be honest, I couldn't tell you.
Oh!
Secret?
Maybe not secret.
Hmm.
Where are you?
I hear you in there.
I hear him.
He's mostly...
groaning and groaning.
That was the classic boomer era.
I glitched the boss strut.
I can't believe it.
I seriously thought it would take me a couple tries.
But it was just...
It just happened.
I told you guys I was... I cheesed.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh!
Ow!
Ouchie, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I don't know if I'm supposed to be going this way or what.
Oh, here we go.
Alright.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, there are pain elementals in here.
Or lost souls, I mean.
Ah, shoot.
Okay.
Oh, not today, sir.
Oh, no, that's the wrong thing.
This one.
Always love watching your streams on kick.
Yep, that's me.
Notorious kick stream.
Wait, okay, so...
Oh, this is what opened.
Oh my god.
Pinky!
Ah!
Yeah, oh.
Uh.
I messed up.
Yeah, come back.
Idiot.
Everybody.
All of them.
Stupid idiots.
Pinky jump scare.
They always do that to me, don't they?
I don't know who I just killed.
I always, I just kill, I just kill.
No?
Any secrets?
Take some clips.
Oh, ah!
Ah!
Stop shooting at me from everywhere!
Oh my god, from literally every angle.
Chill out!
I'm gonna run out of bullets at this rate.
I'm gonna die at this rate.
Can we calm down?
Okay.
Time to snipe with a shotgun.
As usual.
Hey!
Where did you guys come from, too?
Stop shooting at me.
Everybody's ridiculous.
We need more bullets.
I can't snipe from here, I think.
guys i think it's a lost cause well i say that but you know
it's doom
it's doom this level looks fancy yeah it does look kind of
fancy are those the guys that were shooting at me i think
red card ah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh oh i'm gonna be out of
bullets real soon.
Uh-oh.
I need to use my fist.
I'm stuck on the wall!
Oh, I have to use my fists!
Uh-oh.
I'm in... Oh, wait, wait.
Oh, thank goodness.
Thank goodness.
Oof!
I could have punched him.
I think I could have taken him out.
That guy dropped a shotgun?
Which one?
Oh, this guy?
Oh, thank you.
Yeah.
Legends are true.
Mint guy is real.
rip and tear rip and tear no secret no no secret um i don't
think you'd be camping oh anyway
that's fancy
Is this level supposed to just not give you anything?
Is that why it's, you know, is that why it's so...
Oh my gosh.
Oh my goodness.
Is that why it's a harder level?
They just don't...
You can't punch people.
Yes, I can, Jackie!
Come on.
Have some more faith in me.
Give me stuff.
Give me nothing.
Yes, Queen, give me nothing.
Nice.
Oh!
Oh, hit hard.
Um...
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Yes, give me everything.
Got him.
Easy peasy.
Lemon squeezy, everybody.
worries here but like i said since i did say i'll do karaoke
um and honestly i guess the stream doesn't need to be too
long because i uh wait where was the blue door i don't even
remember doesn't need to be too long since i uh have done
everything um uh well not everything you know what i mean
though um we'll just do maybe a level or two or something
and then um then we can oh oh no that was the secret door i
went through um where was the blue oh i'm berserk i'm i'm
berserking out i'm berserking out final boss good luck man
oh thanks i needed it then i don't need it now what am i
hearing where do i go am i where's the blue door Am I crazy?
Did you guys see a blue door?
I wasn't down here.
Does he know?
Wait, what do I know?
Oh.
Q.
Is it that over there?
That bright light?
You are crazy, yes.
I'm crazy good at the game.
Oh, maybe it's...
through here oh hello why are you in here oh my god why are
you both in here where did you guys come from maybe
oh maybe it's down there eating mike tyson's but thank you
thank you for the gifted is it down here let's try it let's
check this out
Oh, I got the super shotgun.
Wait, how do I get back up?
Oh, it's like that.
The legend.
Guys.
I think I have no idea.
Wait, there's a door right there.
Looks like you need to raise that bridge.
Yeah, I didn't...
I don't think I missed a...
Oh, maybe it's timed here, right?
No, it's on, right?
Yeah, it's on.
Hmm.
I didn't think I missed anything.
I'm lost as well.
Is there a switch here that I didn't see?
Might be.
Switch here?
No?
Now I'm all the way back at the beginning.
Another switch panel.
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I didn't realize they
were different.
Ah!
Oh, my God.
Um, um, um, hello, hold on.
This was unfair.
This was very unfair.
Stop it.
I accidentally blasted myself.
Because I picked up the rocket launcher.
Well, we found the blue door, you guys.
Aw.
Aw, we lost...
We have a shotgun.
shotgun good good good can't grab yours give me your clip oh
give me your shotgun shells there we go already dead what a
loser wait i think i heard a guy did i see one over there no
i think i'm growing i think i'm crazy i think i'm crazy And
the yellow key.
Oh.
Don't shoot!
Oh shoot.
Fine.
Thanks for the turn.
Thank you so much.
Ah!
What keeps...
Oh.
I got you.
I got it.
Easy peasy.
Did you take your meds?
No.
That's what I have to say about that.
Taking my meds!
Oh, rockets.
Now we go back to this room?
In here?
Oh!
Who just entered?
Did I kill him?
I don't think I did.
What if I just blast him?
Who is that in there?
Oh.
Oh, I can't blast him.
Okay, let's just run.
Yeah!
Ah!
This is more than I bargained for!
Why is there a barrier to hell all of a sudden?
Oh,
now they were right there!
Oh my gosh.
I get stuck up on the walls so easily.
Stop it!
Ugh.
Who's still aiming at me?
Oh, I don't have any bullets here.
Oh gosh, oh gosh.
Hit the thing.
Oh my god, there's more of them.
I'm out of bullets.
I can only rocket launch!
Oh my god.
Yippee!
Rocket launch!
No!
Not today.
Oh my god.
I think they're too far away.
If I try it... Oh my god.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, this is such a mess!
Get him!
How did you take a rocket to the face?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh my god.
They're behind the bars!
Oh, buh buh buh buh.
There's this guy.
I think I got him.
This guy.
Death.
Maybe death.
Nice rocket.
I only have A left.
Okay, I think I got him.
Oh, I picked up shotgun shells.
Somewhere.
Yippee!
Oh, more rockets!
Maybe they do love me.
Who just entered the room?
Not anymore.
How is this level more stressful than the last level?
They just always exceed my expectations, you know?
Wait, is that a guy over there?
No, he's not moving.
Okay, let's go.
Exit.
Wait, what's this?
This?
Nothing.
Oh, holy moly.
Oh.
Yeah.
Thanks for the membership.
Thank you.
20% secrets.
Hmm.
Oh my god.
Should I kill him?
Should I take him out?
He hasn't...
Take him out from behind his back.
It's so sad.
Look at that butt.
Yeah!
That's an imp.
That's an imp we're ogling right now.
And a butthole.
How do I get out of here?
Like, just like that.
Don't try me.
Don't do not try me.
I'm a different ghost.
I've beat the mother demon.
Achieve the mother demon.
Do not.
Save?
I guess we can save.
We'll save over level 21.
Wait.
Oh, no.
What does this count as?
Level 35!
I hear them.
I hear them doing their ugly whispers.
Wait, was there something here?
Yeah, chain line.
Yeah, take that.
And take that.
they're whispering about me they're just oh oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god hey i see you over there he's just
like oh i'm here too i'm late for the party baby
nice moves is there anything here why is there just a random
Oh!
Ow!
How did that miss?
We got him.
Gaming?
Gaming, everybody?
Gaming.
Minto Gaming.
Everybody remember.
I hear somebody.
So as soon as we get up here, I know there's going to be
some whispering.
Who is there?
Minto Gaming.
Obama?
What?
He has nothing to do with this.
He's not taking my credit.
Ew.
Maybe it was them.
Maybe they were the whispers.
How do I get this armor?
Super shotgun.
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay.
I heard it.
Run, run, run!
Yippee!
Secret.
Electric berry!
Is it him?
Was it you?
No?
There's more.
Oh.
There they are.
Uh
oh.
Who just came out?
More of them.
Oh, God.
In-fight.
Yeah, in-fight, you dummies.
Oh, my God.
There's so much happening here.
Whoa!
Oh, oh.
What?
There's a spider, too?
Oh, oh, he killed him.
He killed him.
Okay.
I can take him out.
Oh.
That was a little overkill, but you know.
They're giving me energy things, but I don't have a energy
gun.
Where's my energy going?
Oh!
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Spider squished.
Poor little spitter.
I need more shotgun shells, though.
Oh, box.
Boxo.
What did that open up?
Anything?
Oh, I'll take that.
I'll take that.
Oh, here, here, here.
Nice.
They say choose one.
No, this is so unfair.
Do you want the blueberry or do you want the plasma gun?
It was my birthday a few weeks ago.
Well, happy few weeks ago, birthday.
ADHD agenda?
Is that what you name it?
Wait, or did that say head?
The head agenda.
The agenda.
There's a spider behind you.
No!
Blueberry all the way.
Oh, we could get a new gun.
This is unfair.
Why would you make me choose?
Only blueberry.
Wait.
Yubi!
So unfair.
Oh, this opened up.
The lighting in here is a little freaky, right?
Take those rockets.
Wait, can I run from here to get that blueberry, I wonder?
Ah!
Oh, I got invisibility!
Oh, that's what that did.
Fun?
what is something lower what's the point of having a
visibility if i don't know where to go uh uh hold on uh once
again um i open i activated something and is it over there
maybe it's here i'm partially invisible don't bother me oh
here You can't see me!
How can you see me?
Oh my gosh.
You can't see me.
I'm John Cena.
I'm John Cena!
It's only partial.
No, no, it's real.
It's 100%.
Believe, believe, believe.
Nice.
How do I...
That's how I do.
Or maybe not.
Oh god.
Oh god!
Don't open the door, you guys.
It's scary out there.
Just don't open the door.
I should have changed the chain gun.
Anybody else?
They're like, ha ha, you thought it was that lever because
it's yellow and the key is yellow.
But no, it is this lever over here.
Dummy.
Get played.
Howdy Mentopia, have a nice day.
Thank you, Adeen.
Thank you so much.
Oh, I don't have the red key.
I'm dumb.
I knew that.
Yellow, yellow.
those tricky level designers the demons kind of know what's
up but also how do they like get anything done you know wait
I'm stuck how do they where was yellow again oh I remember
hi John Cena I loved you and Bubble Bee and Suicide Squad
hope you have fun hosting Shark Week yes I knew that I was
hosting that thanks for letting me know
Yeah, get stun locked, dummy.
There's more over here.
Whoa!
Yeah, get stun locked, dummy.
Okay.
What's in this area now?
Take all your bullets.
Energy cell for a plasma gun that I forfeited.
Thank you.
What's this one?
Maybe it's a...
What's the word?
Um...
Rockets.
Well, how do I...
I'm...
Hold on.
I think I'm...
Oh, here we go.
Wow.
There wasn't an enemy immediately.
As soon as I walked in.
Oh.
Oh my god.
This was a spitter, Damon.
The spitter was right here the whole time.
Blue.
Come on.
That has to be something.
You.
That looks like a trap.
Where's...
the next one what i keep putting it weakest trap ever too
easy five out of ten five out of ten oh yeah we want this
one too easy to determine that it was a trap you know i i
called it from a mile away whoever designed that one it was
like their first day on the job they're like what if we let
what if we what if it was like a little candy like a you
follow the armor you'd be like oh yeah i What am I on this
one?
Ah!
Maybe it was his second day.
Oh my god, there's another spider demon!
Ooh, piece of candy.
I just keep following it.
And, um, ha ha.
Not just one spider demon, but two.
And then three.
Oh my god.
They're doing...
They want me to be on this side.
Oh, okay.
Are you sure?
What a...
Oh god!
Oh!
Ouchie, ouchie.
I think I got him.
But...
there was a this guy with the long hair don't do it don't
you do it don't you i don't want to see your ugly faces i
don't want to see your ugly faces i want to see them i don't
want to see them i can't tell if i'm getting him or not what
is this what is going on oh my god there's several of them
there's several of them can we all like fight each other you
know?
Ah!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
He's coming in here!
You see, you're not allowed in!
This is private property!
Did I get them both?
Nope.
Oh my god.
Oh, he's still here?
Okay.
Something opened.
But what?
Here?
Oh!
Oh,
wait.
How am I supposed to reach that?
Wait!
Hmm?
Interesting.
Oh, maybe for back here?
No.
Aim up.
Okay, sorry.
Super shotgun?
No.
Jump.
That's my favorite mechanic.
into them being able to jump, you know?
Really great thing that they added.
A raised platform.
It's over...
It's right here, right?
Yeah, I can see it.
I can see.
I don't see where there's a raised platform, though.
Don't see.
No!
Use the rocket for the splash damage?
I don't know.
Strange.
It's a little peculiar.
a button.
Did I get all of them?
Yeah.
I'm trying to make sure I got every, like, weapon, or all
this stuff stuff.
Hmm.
Second floor.
Oh, see?
I missed that shotgun.
Okay.
Huh.
You can jump in the newer ones.
That's very true.
They did include that.
Have I gone through here?
I don't know if I have.
I must have, right?
Oh, yeah.
I just missed that rocket.
Oh, yeah, because that's where the line of the thingies
were.
Yeah, I want that.
I see the weapon.
Is that the BFG?
Oh, yeah, a little candy trail.
I wonder if I needed to have gotten it when this platform
was...
I think I missed my chance.
Because this platform was raised.
No!
Dang.
Wait, oh there.
Uh-oh.
Oh wait.
What?
No?
What just opened?
What opened?
Oh wait!
Oh!
Now we can do it!
Right?
Yes, yes, yes!
Hey, open up.
Yippee!
Okay, we got it.
Now, we have...
What did we just grab?
The red key?
I don't remember where those were at.
The red key.
Well, not here, obviously.
We go this way.
Yellow key.
Maybe in here?
Okay.
Have you been here the whole time?
No, I think you just spawned, right?
Grab all these clips.
As much as we can.
I'm running around.
Let's be the sound.
And he was bored later.
Where was...
Was it...
Oh, I don't think that.
Where was?
It was in here.
Oh, yes.
Uh-oh.
That's a lost soul.
Maybe?
Oh, you guys are jailed because you're all...
You all got caught!
That makes you really lame and stupid.
Oh, how did you live that?
Only idiots get caught and put in jail.
weren't good enough oh shit oh it's a bear to fell oh no oh
no oh no oh oh oh oh I got him I got his butt oh no oh and
then as soon as I press this button we're gonna all lower
and the whole army is gonna come out I hear them all can I
get them from here 9?
Oh my gosh, where did you come from?
It's like, I've been around.
I've been around.
Let's see if we can get these guys, because they will surely
gang up on us, along with other guys.
Hello?
Maybe that was the last one.
That's timed.
Nice.
Genius.
Yippee!
Okay guys, I'm gonna do a little bit of karaoke now.
Or do you want me to do karaoke at the Chibi debut?
Which would be better?
Honestly, I have like nothing planned.
So maybe we'll just keep this as Doom related and then we
can do the karaoke during the Chibi debut.
Hmm.
Both.
Look at you, you're so self-fulfilling.
No, I'm just kidding.
You want your cake and you want to eat it too.
This one looks sick.
Look at that guy over there.
Oh, what a warm welcome.
I want to keep playing.
I will save.
Maybe I'll, like, play these off stream.
Maybe I'll finish these levels off stream or something.
Or maybe one day if I'm failing board, I'll just stream
them, you know, whatever.
But this level has a really cool look.
I would keep going but um like I said I have a uh I have
another stream in one hour and I would like to eat before
then so thank you guys for um watching me tease people are
gonna be like wow look at that stream length it's a whole
hour it took her an hour to beat the final boss wow Minto
gaming is not real and then they're gonna watch and see that
beat the boss in five minutes.
Thanks for the tutorial.
Of course.
Of course, of course.
Thank you guys for watching.
Thank you guys for hanging out and I'll see you guys in an
hour if you want to see my new little GB model.
It's so cute.
And yeah.
Otamintau.
Andrea goes like it's for the 20 Gifted.
Frog.
Thank you for the Akasupa and Gato Ruffin.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Oh, thank you so much.
And, um, yeah.
Awesome, meantime, everyone.
See you in an hour if I see you.
And if not, if you're watching the VOD, I might see you in
an hour.
I don't know.
Who knows?
In another stream.
You might be watching this and I could be streaming at this
very moment.
Maybe.
Who knows?
Bye-bye.